hello guys I'm Ryan writes hi I'm Lena
Myers
we're gonna check out from couch tomato
they do some fun videos this guy there
was this video that he's like hey man I
like your channel so I want you to do a
voiceover for me but he wasn't telling
me what the video was exactly about I
just had to record some lines so I'm in
this video you hear my voice it's thirty
reasons child's play 2 which is the
Chuckie movie Chuckie part 2 and Toy
Story 3 are the same movie featuring the
real rejects thank you
when I was little I saw this movie like
a million times and although I really
couldn't quite put my finger on why I
kept suffering from horrible nightmares
years later I revisit it and well now I
know we begin our story in for the
record I like to add that both Luke
Skywalker and Princess Leia grew up
without their mother or father and both
of them turned out fine in my opinion
stories about this little kid named Andy
in his relationship with the doll from
the previous film in the first scene you
make eye contact kind of tended with the
toy with the knife problem pun intended
again a little creepy but honestly a
case could be made that the Twitter toys
just want to get up close and personal
with Andy there's even a secret where
the toy makes a prank called Andy spawn
just to get him to play with them the
plan fails and lands on his face because
when Andy goes to licking his toy chest
about 10 seconds later he sees his old
doll and storms out of the room right
after his Astra's mom tries to get rid
of the toys and the frustrating part is
this could have easily been avoided if
the toy would open up his mouth and ask
to ask his mom to leave him alone but
every time the humans come around the
toy does this hello my baby hello my
baby frog day doesn't sale work when
they eat the dog buries women - good guy
dogs and some dirt you know from Jump
Street he's about that life if you need
more convincing The Bachelor hitches are
right on the back of a vehicle and when
the ETA strikes zero he arrives at a
school for little kids when the kids are
at recess it's a little - rated R for my
blood
daycare or more like don't care but
don't boom shhh at night one of the
characters gets jump scared the hell out
of and they tie his self-respect
along with his arms and legs later on
and yes to move out and it's timing
couldn't be any worse because the good
toys need a friend now more than ever
and it sucks because the bad guys
manipulate the good guys so now that
good guys turn on the good guys if that
makes any sense one night a character's
reminiscing on a swing and then the
camera pans low and then the audience
sees that there's a good guy doll hiding
underneath the swing and if you think
that something smells fishy you have a
keen sense of smell because you're
obviously right the bad dog that was
thrown into the garbage earlier escapes
then the main characters catch a ride on
the back of a truck and afterwards the
stakes must smoke marijuana because the
stakes get high as hell when they arrive
to the place with the conveyor belt
thingy it looks like the main characters
are about to get smother but they're
bailed out at the last
immediately after the good guy doll is
about to get melted and he's all like
you must count the amount of dance given
when the other guy just stands there and
lets it happen for a split second you
think they might get burned alive but no
they don't and the hero comes to their
rescue instead at the end the evil toy
gets exactly what he deserves and has to
hold his breath against his will and any
proves he's growing up when he turns his
back on all those toys and leaves him
behind those are 24 reasons these movies
of the same but before I hit the theme
music button anything that I write just
a few for starters you gave two reasons
instead of one at the last one both
dolls have had to hold their breath as a
form of punishment at the end hmm
secondly is it awkward that the most
unbelievable part to me in this movie is
not that the toys are alive but the fact
that rotary phones are so popular in a
cinematic universe post 1980s that's me
statistics show that families of people
suffering from gambling addiction are
more likely to face domestic violence
because gambling addicts most commonly
engage in frequent quarrels and fights
with members in the household so the
main characters trials in this movie may
come as no surprise and they're the
reason to destroy the toys bad behavior
is the replacement toy I'd be upset too
if I came home and my owner upgraded
while I was gone the fifth reason and
also one of the dumbest products since I
have ever seen is the alkaline batteries
the toys have underneath their backs
alkaline won't sell another pack off the
shelf once the consumer realizes if you
put that crap in your toy it comes alive
lastly it's so easy to get the wrong
message with text emails or letters
prime example is one of the toys put his
heart and soul into a letter but the
receiver gets the wrong idea and raises
an eyebrow when she or they reads it and
gets the wrong idea and I'm done not bad
not bad at all it was thirty reasons
these movies are the same you agree Yes
No maybe so if not politely share your
thoughts in the comment section below
and click the subscribe button for more
24 reason videos how about a round of
applause for Ryan from real rejects
[Applause]
real rejects is a YouTube channel where
Ryan and company react you dog
I know July trailers so I react to the
trailers and review them so you could
watch me watch trailers while watching
my channel coulda said it better myself
rain for funny reactions movie review
sketches and blocks check out Ronnie's
channel by clicking the link and tell
him I sent you
[Music]
wow I have an exquisite voice yeah let's
just react this is review your voice I
don't I don't get why there needs to be
a camera all there needs to be is a
microphone did you hear me yeah did you
hear me yes wow I could be on radio I
could do podcasts
she beat car dude can you guys just
comment below and tell me how much you
liked my voice as I have an awesome
voice baby how's my voice you think so
yeah I think I know I must have sex with
my voice I'll provide my voice baby sing
into your lips you know what I mean what
am i doing Wow well anyway don't dude a
great [ __ ] job again I've seen this
guy's channel before and so I'm like I'd
love to do some voiceover for you it's
amazing how many he came up with yes did
he really like how did when did he
figure out like that they were so alike
I don't know he here's what I think I
think he puts a lot more work into his
videos than I do
and that's how he's able to find this
information
yes he does work time and research I'm
like it's a reaction so the less I know
the better the one realer it is you're
failing I like the dynamic of this one
especially because sometimes like he did
one like Man of Steel and the passion of
the christ' but I was already able to
see how they are very similar ago
Superman can is already derivative of
the Christ story but when you see
something like
child's play 2 and Toy Story 3 and then
you're like you see this is like you
know what these movies are pretty
similar because he doesn't just take a
few facts he goes through the whole plot
to show you not just these little
nitpicky things a lot of the plot points
are very similar whoever created Toy
Story 3 or wrote the script probably
just watched jaws plays how they do it
with like Sauron ripped off the story of
child's play two thieves a comedy movie
they should sue they should sue Toy
Story creators but listen back to me my
voice when I talk about my voice I go in
to this voice over enemy I should do a
voice over animation watch give me a
character who's in cartoon character
laugh hi I'm Mickey Mouse next one
spongebob are you doing I'm spongebob
[Music]
watch I'm gonna prove to you just how
good my voice is anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to it you can subscribe today and become
a reject Selina Meyers hosts an event
called colour my energy where it's an
array a combination of wonderful artists
from poetry to musicians to some
comedians even and she has a youtube
channel as well that you should check
out you could follow us on all of our
social networks Facebook Twitter
Instagram youporn pornhub redtube and
many other porn sites we are the real
rejects